♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELL, FOR A LOT OF
CALENDAR YEAR 2018, THE CREEPY
PORN LAWYER WAS A BONA FIDE STAR
ON CABLE NEWS.
CNN HAD HIM ON SO OFTEN, HE
BROUGHT A COVERED DISK TO THE
COMPANY PICNIC IT OVER AT MSNBC,
FAMILIARITY THAT ENCHANTMENT.
THEY WERE STARTING TO WORSHIP
THE GUY.
>> HE IS A BEAST.
HE KEEPS POPPING DONALD TRUMP
AND ALL OF HIS FOLKS IN THE
MOUTH.
HE MAY BE THE FAVORITE OF THE
REPUBLICAN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> ENOUGH ALREADY, MICHAEL, I'VE
SEEN YOU EVERYWHERE.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE LEFT TO SAY?
I WAS WRONG, BROTHER APPEARED TO
BE ONE SINCERE QUESTION: HOW
DUMB WOULD YOU HAVE TO BE TO
FIND THE CREEPY PORN LAWYER
IMPRESSIVE?
HE WAS SUCH A TRANSPARENT FRAUD,
SUCH A TOTAL CON, IN AND ONLY
FOR HIMSELF THERE NO QUESTION
ABOUT THAT EVER.
WE TOLD HIM SO DIRECTLY THE
NIGHT HE CAME TO VISIT US ON A
SHOW.
WATCH.
>> Tucker: YOU PROFITED FROM
STORMY DANIELS, DON TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF FREE
MEDIA ON THE BASIS OF YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH HER, AND
SHE IS WORKING IN STRIP CLUBS.
YOU ARE EXPLAINING HER, AND YOU
KNOW THAT I DID WANT YOU PAYING
HER SOME OF WHAT YOU ARE MAKING?
>> SIR, THIS IS ABSURD.
>> Tucker: BUT ANSWER MY
QUESTION, WHY ARE YOU RACH AND
YOUR CLIENT IS WORKING IN ZITI
STRIP CLUBS.
I KNOW YOU HAVEN'T PAID YOUR
TAXES THERE LIKE SO MANY
LAWYERS, YOU ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF HER, AND YOU POSE
AS A FEMINIST HERO BECAUSE YOU
ARE SAYING LESS AND THE OTHER
CHANNELS LET YOU GET AWAY WITH
IT.
BUT YOU'RE AN EXPLOITER OF THE
WOMAN, AND YOU SHOULD BE ASHAMED
OF IT.
>> Tucker: WE HATE TO BRAG,
ALMOST NEVER DO, BUT TONIGHT WE
ARE GOING TO MAKE A RARE
EXCEPTION.
WE WERE RIGHT ABOUT HIM.
TODAY, THE CREEPY PORN LAWYER
WAS INDICTED ON A NEW SET OF
CRIMINAL CHARGES BUT THEY ARE
SAYING HE DEFRAUDED, YES, STORMY
DANIELS PAIR TURNS OUT HE WAS
NOT A FEMINIST HERO.
ACCORDING TO THE INDICTMENT, HE
USED IT TO FORGE HER SIGNATURE
AND USED HER BOOK ADVANCE ON
HOTELS, RESTAURANTS, AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
ALL THE WHILE, STORMY DANIELS
WORKED IN STRIP CLUBS TO PAY HER
BILLS.
CREEPY PORN LAWYER LIVED WITH
PURITY ON MISFORTUNE.
IS ANYBODY OUTSIDE OF CABLE NEWS
SURPRISED BY THIS?
A FRIEND OF OURS, JOINS US
TONIGHT.
I KNOW YOU ARE NOT SURPRISED BY
THIS.
THE WHOLE PRIME TIME LINE UP ON
A BUNCH OF OTHER CHANNELS MUST
HAVE THEIR JAWS OPEN, THEY
WANTED HIM TO BE PRESIDENT.
>> YEAH, THEY WERE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT HIM.
HE RAN THROUGH THE DETAILS VERY
WELCOME, ESPECIALLY LOOKING BACK
AT THAT INTERVIEW ON WHAT YOU
SAID AND HAVE BEEN SAYING.
OH, NO, IT WASN'T EXPLODING HER.
IT TURNS OUT, RIGHT, THAT HE WAS
FORGING HER NAME TO DIVERT FUNDS
THAT WERE COMING TO HER FOR HER
BOOK DEAL AND PUTTING THEM IN
HIS ACCOUNT.
AND HE SAYS COME IN HIS DEFENSE,
HE WAS TWEETING TODAY,
BASICALLY, I WAS OWED THAT
BECAUSE I WAS THE LAWYER.
THEN WHY DID YOU HAVE TO FORGE
HER NAME?
AND WHY, THEN, DID YOU TELL HER,
ACCORDING TO THE CRIMINAL
INDICTMENT FROM THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT, WHY DID YOU TELL HER
THAT THE PUBLISHER WAS USED TO
PAY?
HE'S LYING TO HER, HE'S LYING TO
EVERYONE TO DIVERT THE MONEY.
HIS DEFENSE IS I WAS OWED IT.
THAT'S JUST ONE SMALL THING.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE WHOLE
THING, WITH NIKE, HE EXTORTED
NIKE, WAITING UNTIL THE EARNINGS
PERIOD.
THIS IS ALL ALLEGED, AND
ACCORDING TO WHAT THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT AND FEDS ARE SAYING, HE
WAITED UNTIL NIKE'S EARNINGS.
MAX, WHEN THEY WOULD BE MOST
VULNERABLE, AND HE SAID YOU HAVE
DONE WRONG, AND I AM GOING TO
HAVE A PRESS CONFERENCE IF YOU
DON'T HIRE ME RIGHT NOW TO AUDIT
YOUR COMPANY FOR $20 MILLION,
AND I WILL BE YOUR INTERNAL
COUNSEL TO AUDIT YOUR COMPANY.
OR THE CAVEAT WAS YOU CAN JUST
GIVE ME $22 MILLION, AND I WILL
BE QUIET AND GO AWAY.
THIS IS ALL IN THE PAPERWORK
THAT CAME OUT TODAY THAT WE
READ, AND HE IS TWEETING BACK IN
HIS DEFENSE, I WILL BE
EXONERATED, I WAS OLD THIS
MONEY, ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
CASES.
ALL TOLD, HE COULD GO TO JAIL
FOR 404 YEARS, AND IN MY BOOK,
IT'S REALLY NOT ENOUGH FOR
EVERYTHING THAT HE DID.
HE ALSO HAD BANK FRAUD, WIRE
FRAUD, FILED FOR BANKRUPTCY,
LIGHT IN THAT PROCEEDING -- ALL
ALLEGED, AGAIN, ALLEGED.
BUT THIS IS A LOT PILING ON IN
CALIFORNIA, IN NEW YORK, ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
IT KIND OF HITS ON TWO THEMES
THAT OUR VIEWERS LOVE HERE.
NUMBER ONE IS HYPOCRISY.
AND THAT IS WHAT YOU REALLY PUT
OUT THERE WHEN YOU HAVE THE
INTERVIEW WITH HIM, WHERE HE IS
STANDING THERE,
HOLIER-THAN-THOU, FILLED WITH
SANCTIMONY, SAYING THIS PERSON
BROKE THE LAW.
THIS PERSON IS IMMORAL.
I'M STANDING UP FOR WHAT IS
RIGHT, AND THE LAW, THIS ANSWER
THAT.
AND HERE, ACCORDING TO THESE
OFFICIALS, AND THESE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS, HE IS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CRIMINALS AND
PREDATORS OUT THERE, ACCORDING
TO WHAT THEY ARE SAYING.
THE OTHER THING WHEN I THINK IS
REALLY INTERESTING, THAT
YOUR VIEWERS LOVE, IS THE IRONY.
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT TO THINK THAT
HE WAS DOING THIS FOR A LONG
TIME, AND THERE ARE MANY CLIENTS
HE'S ACCUSED OF DEFRAUDING.
HE SPENT THE MONEY ON FERRARIS,
A PRIVATE PLANE, THEY SAY.
HE WAS LIVING THE LIFESTYLE, AND
DEFRAUDING PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING
PAID FOR LEGITIMATE THINGS.
BUT HE DIDN'T GET CAUGHT UNTIL
HE WENT ALL OVER TELEVISION.
UNTIL HE WAS DRUNK ON HIS OWN
SAYINGS.
HE HAD PEOPLE LIKE STEPHANIE
RULE OVER AT MSNBC
CELEBRATING HIM, RIGHT?
UNTIL HE HAD --
>> Tucker: BUT WHERE IT IS
JUDGMENT?
IT WAS SO OBVIOUS.
I ACTUALLY FEEL SORRY FOR HIM AT
THIS STAGE.
THERE IS CLEARLY SOMETHING WRONG
WITH HIM.
I DON'T WANT TO SPECULATE, BUT
THERE'S CLEARLY SOMETHING
WRONG -- THERE HAS ALWAYS BEEN
SOMETHING WRONG WITH THE GUY
BARED ANY PERSON WHO SPENT
2 MINUTES WITH HIM WE KNOW THAT,
AND YET SOMEHOW THEY DIDN'T KNOW
THAT?
THESE PURVEYORS OF FACTS.
SPEAK WITH YOU KNOW WHY, BECAUSE
THEY WERE DOING THE WORK THAT
THEY WANTED DONE.
HE DIDN'T GO AFTER BRETT
KAVANAUGH, HE HAD STORMY
DANIELS TO GO AFTER THE
PRESIDENT, HE WAS DOING THE
BIDDING OF WHAT THE OTHER
NETWORKS WANTED, SO THEY LOOK
PAST IT THERE TO BE ONE DOING
THE WORK OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> HAD HE NOT GOTTEN DRUNK ON
HIS OWN FAME, HE MIGHT HAVE
GOTTEN AWAY WITH IT.
>> Tucker: IT IS ALMOST LIKE A